it is often believed that in
relationships opposites attract
like two magnets compelled together by
the force of their opposite poles two
humans are attracted into a bond of love
and intimacy when they are opposites of
one another the point of a relationship
is to have someone to share life with
not only that but someone to help
navigate through and improve life with
perhaps it is possible that opposites
are often believed to attract because
they create a dynamic exchange of
personal improvement if a couple is to
some level opposite of one another when
each person brings their views and
personality to the table they can
provide alternative insight and
perspective into each other's lives a
check and balance of sorts where the
contrast between each partner provides
equilibrium to each other's personality
type this is of great value because our
personalities can be very elusive and
consuming after we have become attached
and conditioned by our personality they
tend to run away with us we should
appreciate and embrace our unique
personalities but their force can often
cause us to become complacent and
stagnant they can close us off from
considering and executing improvements
in our self and our life and therefore
it is very beneficial to have someone
who can help us consider and mediate our
personality from a different vantage
point the likely truth is that a happy
long-term relationship forms out of a
balance of being both opposite and
similar an elaborate mix of
complementary and contrasting
personality traits layered on to one
another
in an order that provides balance to
both individuals but regardless of how
true it is or isn't that opposites
attract there will always be some level
of difference in the personalities and
perspectives of two people and what's
more important than anything else is
both partners being aware of each
other's differences and possessing the
willingness to work through them and
meet in the middle for a relationship to
survive
we're both individuals feel inspired
challenged and benefited each side must
be willing to give up a little bit of
themselves in order to receive a little
bit from their partner to be open to the
ways in which their partner lives and
the potential benefits it can have on
their life and the relationship as a
whole it is this exchange that brings
balance to each person
neutralizes complacency and facilitates
a relationship of lasting and potent
love
[Music]
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder